[Musique]
montréal a au cours des vingt dernières
années perdues sont je ne sais quoi même
ailleurs au canada
on associe plus le style et la mode
autant à montréal qu'auparavant quand on
additionne tout ça on peut avoir des
faits réels qui sont juste pour la
partie du loyer de 30 à 50%
je veux rentrer un coup salaire juste
licou salers et 15 à 20% et les loyers
le sait c'est commun dans l'industrie
maintenant de tolérer un magasin mobile
gilles fortin les propriétaires des
boutiques tristan il revient sur les
moments difficiles que vit l'industrie
du vêtement du québec
moi je comprends pas que du bon peuvent
rester en affiche son double tree vous
donner 40 % fait essayer de comprendre
vous avez 15 à 20 % de salaire et vous
avez un peu près 25% de loyer faut pas
jeter une chemise 80 45 avec cinq cent
mille pièces de taxe soda 2000 pièces
par jour mais c'est un élément qui fait
partie de tant de choses qui rendent le
commerce plus du ciron blanc souvent les
ventes internet pour les difficultés du
commerce en détail les détaillants ils
écrasent sur ces chargeurs centres
commerciaux où vivent encore dans le
penser pense qu'on peut augmenter les
loyers nets et pendant ce temps alors il
surveille plus ou moins bien leurs frais
généraux
c'est pas eux qui sont responsables des
taxes il ya beaucoup de transactions
immobilières qui font monter la valeur
de l'immeuble est celui qui écope
baisser le détaillant a mouais j'ai vu
quelques les sessions et puis celle là
j'ai l'impression que ces panneaux
session c'est une crevaison alors on
essaye tous de sauver et de revenir
comme c'était quand on on fait face à la
pire chose qui va nous arriver c'est un
changement d'habitudes des consommateurs
et ça ça pardonne pas aller magasiner
des magasins mais pas acheter mais après
ce faire la commande pour chercher le
maire plus l'internet
ils sont absolument
coin sable dans le moment le client veut
ce qu'il veut quand il veut et où il le
veut il va l'acheter dans un magasin wal
d'acheter son téléphone ne vaut pas le
lâche t on joindre la banque et
spécialiste du commerce au détail aux
hec montréal l'école des hautes études
commerciales et marketing pour répondre
à ses attentes et même parfois les
entreprises qui vont continuer de faire
de maintenir leur modèle parce que ça
fonctionnait dans la salle est toujours
un peu été ici vous êtes dans notre
atelier de création donc on réinvente la
marque à chaque saison c'est ce qu'on se
dit entre nous alors cette philosophie
là de toujours vouloir faire mieux et
omniprésente au sein de notre compte de
notre compagnie pour au sein de notre
équipe
philippe dubuc est un designer canadien
né à montréal en 1966 de réputation
internationale
il est l'un des porte flambeau de la
nouvelle génération de créateurs mode du
québec
il a déclaré faillite en 2006 2
concernant alors que sa boutique de la
rue saint-denis au centre ville de
montréal
ben c'est pas juste des montréal bien
sûr c'est d'aider la cdd la création
puis l'industrie québécoise entre autres
you la grappe industrielle à la mode
québec qui s'est formée cette grappe est
là aussi pour unir les forces au temps
des détaillants des manufacturiers des
propriétaires du sinn autant de gens qui
ont des services à l'industrie des
créateurs de mode comme moi espérons que
de ça on va pouvoir créer ensemble soit
des nouveaux produits de nouvelles
associations d'une
collaboration aussi ce type de
collaboration le sincère exactement dans
la philosophie de ce que la grappe
industrielle veut eyes on u peu à peu
dans une case à part je pense que 95%
des détaillants qui traverse cette
période très très difficile
ceux qui vont passer à travers ont une
colonne vertébrale très forte
la directrice générale des boutiques de
vêtements pour femmes tristan lily
fortin explique que le monde de la mode
au québec
véritable engin de la mode ou pis il ya
encore 40 ans n'avait pas le choix que
de collaborer
nous on travaille très fort on a une
structure qui nous qui nous permet aussi
qui nous permet de garder notre ligne
directrice est de ne pas couper dans des
choses de pas mélanger qui y en a certes
changé
deux clientèles cibles ou de de laisser
tomber certaines valeurs d'entreprise
qu'on a
je repars de qualité encore parce que
c'est ce qui nous différencie je pense
qu'on reste on a notre équipe de design
la lanterne alors la direction et tout
le reste est clair tout haut malgré la
vague difficile à travers laquelle les
détaillants passeurs selon un reportage
de radio canada international